hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one additional
aspect post on yes is speech in the
symposium that's particularly
interesting in which I think has a lot
of implications for our own time at our
culture is his references to what we can
call paradoxes of love paradoxes of
erotic or romantic love the love of
desire now he has in mind what's going
on in Athens because as I pointed out in
another core concept video he thinks
that the other Greek city-states are you
know sort of like in Goldilocks of story
they're too much or too little they
they're very simple in their approach to
erotic relations particularly between an
older at a younger man where there's a
power imbalance going on either they
rule it out altogether or they let too
many things go you know they say it's
just fine in Athens he says the laws are
more complex and people get confused
about this and he's going to point out
what is actually confusing about this
but I think that we can extend this not
only into our own culture but these are
the sort of things that come up in
respective erotic or romantic love
throughout time and throughout history
these are interesting you know we might
say points of confusion so the context
with this
is relationships and where there's you
might say a power imbalance there is an
imbalance in age there is an older who
is the lover and a younger who is the
beloved but I think that what we're
seeing here could also apply to
relationships where they're not a much
more reciprocal or equal ground with
each other so he brings up certain
Maxim's and these are kind of
interesting there's this Maxim it's
better to love openly than in secret
particularly if the person that you're
loving is somebody who's considered you
know to have a good reputation to be
honorable to have certain gifts even if
they're not really physically attractive
you know the sort of people that we will
say well look I'm in love with that
person because I love their brain their
intellect you know their their ability
to make things happen
is there anything necessarily
paradoxical about that and so far as
worse you know as he's pointing out you
know look normally would be attracted to
those who are good-looking but you know
we get attracted to other people for
other reasons that's not really so
paradoxical for parsimonious although
the thing is paradoxical for some people
that's just sort of the lead-in here's
where it gets a lot more more
interesting the logger is encouraged or
even applauded and think about the way
in which we look at lovers not only in
our day to day life and in and you know
sort of public situations but
particularly in terms of our cultural
products think about romantic comedies
think about sitcoms think about love
songs
think about the ways in which we portray
these these people and he says the lover
is encouraged or applauded for engaging
in conduct that would in other
circumstances or with other motivations
not be seen as so good and here it's
actually worth looking at some of the
examples that he brings up he says
imagine what would happen to a man who
wanted
get money out of someone or a position
or powers of some kind some Authority
and was therefore thought it fit to
behave as the lover behaves towards his
beloved when somebody is displaying the
kind of affection the kind of
infatuation the kind of attraction that
we we some up under this word love we
cut them a certain slack that we
wouldn't if the motive was just to try
to get some money out of it we'd say
somebody like that's a conman
right so they're an operator or if
they're trying to get a position out of
somebody as a matter of fact they may
pretend to be a lover or try to seduce
the other into loving them so that they
can get the position so that they can
get access to their wealth their money
or power when people engage in that sort
of thing you know think about a student
doing anything for a grade you know
anything with the you know significant
quotes we look at that as being you know
kind of tawdry and a sign of bad
character but we allow people to do all
sorts of things for love that from you
know other perspectives are really not a
good idea thinking about all the money
all the wealth that gets gets you know
thrown into grand romantic gestures
people look at that and they're like
yeah makes good sense
think about here's a great example think
about all the money that we spend on
weddings which usually happened you know
in a long enough distance in time for
both partners to get ticked off with all
the preparations that have to take place
but it seemed like a good idea at the
time if this was done for any other
motive how sanyasis saying we would say
what the hell is wrong with you you're
you're doing the wrong thing but when
the water does it then we're like oh
good job keep it up do more of that so
that seems rather paradoxical what are
some of the other things that a lover
does that he gives example urging his
need with prayers and entreaties begging
people you gotta run begging people for
money you're a beggar
okay you go around begging people for a
position again that's that scene is
rather unseemly right doing anything
that it takes to get the to get the job
maybe you're not the right person for
the job in that case but lovers are made
to jump through all sorts of Hoops by
the objects of their affection and
they'll do it and we say that's just
fine as a matter of fact that's looking
it ought to be now we know you really
love them right bowing vows sleeping
upon doorsteps you might think of that
classic scene you know I think it's
insane anything that's been turned into
a meme so many times at the boombox and
John Cusack who I like very much as an
actor that's quite so much of that scene
you know playing the song that's the
sort of stuff that pops audience has in
mind and he's saying this is ridiculous
behavior if you didn't behave in any
other circumstance people would think
that you're a complete nut he goes I
don't a says in short to a slavery which
no slave would endure so it's a slavery
worse than normal slavery and yet the
lover is encouraged in this by other
people well that's rather paradoxical
there's there's a conundrum there right
further waters so the lover is it hasn't
gotten much out of the deal on this and
so far right now the lover gets
something of his or her own the water
gets to break promises as a matter of
fact there's this great line in there
longer the promises are awkward with
these young [ __ ] Kong right a [ __ ]
closes an oath I've heard these people
means of effort any of the things that
have to do with erotic relationships
with sexuality with with all of those
this stuff that we would call romance
right the line is literally there is no
lovers vow why because as soon as the
lover says some sort of promise you can
be sure that they're probably going to
forget about it or it's not going to
apply they get to do this try that be in
finance you put your name on a contract
you actually sign it you don't fulfill
it you'll be in court right
and nobody is going to be able to say
well I didn't really mean it at the time
you know unless they're under duress the
lover gets to make and break vows and
people think that's okay
including the beloved and the lover the
beloved might actually justify that to
their friends or their parents or or to
you know the friends and relatives of
the lover and say oh it's okay that he
or she didn't come through on this
because you know it's the relationship
that matters so that's a paradox as well
here's another paradox if love is so
good if it's so ennobling if it's so
wonderful that we cut people slack when
they're feeling it then why the parents
try to keep the lover from any sort of
access to their child as the beloved if
it's such a great thing
why aren't they like hey it's certainly
taking swim lessons I mean it's better
than being thrown into the deep end go
ahead and date all you want instead
parents actually restrict that sort of
stuff you know a lot of parents are like
well you're not dating until you're 16
or sometimes you know 18 or or whatever
you're not dating while you're under my
roof you're not engaging in these sorts
of relationships kids find all sorts of
ways to circumvent that social media and
texting has you know introduced all
sorts of new wrinkles into that but if
you if you read ancient Greek literature
and ancient Roman literature actually
change the literature of most places you
will find that that young people are
extremely enterprising in figuring out
how to get around parental restrictions
and why are those parental restrictions
there in the first place because it's
it's felt that love is not entirely good
this there's something dangerous about
this there's something that we want to
put off until somebody is really able to
handle it some some parents may actually
try to keep their children from ever
falling in love they they don't allow
them the sort of freedom to do that why
is that the case well again we're
dealing with a paradox another paradox
that he brings up which is again
perfectly applicable to home time
the person who is you know apparent as a
beloved because somebody else loves them
and that maybe makes a gesture or
something like that they're our friends
their peers make fun of them Oh
so-and-so's got a boyfriend so once
those got a girlfriend you know some
flowers come what are those from why
don't you tell the rest of us then
people blush and they want to cover it
up and and hide it and you know I know
this just goes back to the original max
look better to love openly right well is
it better to love openly or is it better
to make some secrets about this people
engaging in what we call PDA public
displays of affection you know they
might get made fun of for for doing that
sort of thing somebody you know think
back to like high school I'm not even
sure if they do this sort of thing
somebody passes a note by the time that
note gets to its intended person other
people are looking at them and saying
AHA there's something going on there
right so again if love is supposed to be
this this really great thing that nobles
us that brings out the best in us you
know that that gets us all you know
charged up that we cut all sorts of
slack for why do we make fun of people
when you know they're not even the one
who's loving but just the one who is the
object of somebody else's love and
desire now there's one other paradox are
these seeming paradox that I want to
bring up that has to do with Pausanias
his own presentation he talked about it
being okay to submit to the the noble
lover right the person who will actually
in a relationship with you make you into
a better person who's not just
interested in dating you or screwing you
or you know having you on their arm or
something like that displaying you the
person who is genuinely concerned with
with you who feels genuine affection for
whom the sexual component might even be
secondary
he said that was okay what if you only
think that it's the good lover but it's
really the bad lover and they throw you
over
and they break your heart now they make
you look like a fool because you gave in
to them you got involved with them in a
romantic or even sexual relationship and
then they dumped you after you know
doing all sorts of other things maybe
you know cheating on you with your
friends emptying your bank accounts
you know sullying your your your good
name pick whatever you like was that a
bad idea here's of the paradox or
seeming paradox comes in yes it was
still a good thing to do why because it
shows that the nobility of character
that the other person didn't have and
that you did have you were submitting to
them you were getting involved with them
because you thought that they were
thereby going to ennoble you in a
long-term relationship so you had good
reasons it's still fundamentally from
Pausanias point of view a good act
although an unfortunate one one that
doesn't come to fruition and the
question that you want to ask yourself
is it really a paradox or isn't it it is
a paradox from the perspective of a kind
of prudishness from a you know very
conventional point of view it's also a
paradox for those who don't love
according to the good kind of love that
palace audience talks about which
doesn't just look at the body doesn't
just look at the superficial isn't just
for today isn't just about sexual
pleasure but is about the the other
person there are many people who are
genuinely and capable not only sharing
that kind of relationship but even
conceding that that's a real thing for
those people this will totally be a
paradox but for the person who has an
ability within them even in just in
gestation even just in development this
probably will not be a paradox it'll
actually be a narrative that could lead
to some some growth